are we heading towards a point of no
return and how do we get back from this
this is the most difficult thing the way
we actually demolish identity politics
and again the the founding engine of
this is disparate impact we have to
counteract the myth of bias that as long
as the only allowable explanation for
socio-economic disparities is the Tana
Hasee Coates view of the world the
Michelle Alexander view of the world
that everything is driven by bias the
aoc world they win hey I'm Dave Rubin
and unless I've been impeached by a
completely partisan vote this is still
the Rubin report as always a quick
reminder to click the subscribe bell so
you guys have a small chance of seeing
our videos right here on the YouTube and
more importantly joining me today is an
author political commentator and fellow
at the Manhattan Institute Heather
McDonald welcome back to the Rubin
report it's such an honour Dave thank
you so much for having me on I'm glad to
have you back had you on about a year
ago and the people they love you that's
what I learned that's what I learned in
the youtube comment section it's just
the or up being in your presence you
know it's there's so much love coming at
you there little spills over whether
you're killing it in the scarf game
today so I feel like I have to be very
sharp thank you brilliant so here we go
so one of the things I wanted to start
with here is something that we discussed
briefly about five or ten minutes in our
last year's review you are a secular
conservative and I think a lot of
conservatives seem to think that that is
either an oxymoron or just simply cannot
exist because conservatism has to have
some sort of religious underpinning so I
thought that would just be an
interesting place for us to pick up the
conversation I based my conservatism on
on empirical truth on what I've observed
in life I can talk about the necessity
of the two-parent family because we can
see empirically what happens when the
marriage norm breaks down in communities
I most traditional value
because I think we have a history of
stability when those are honored I don't
think it's particularly stable to rest a
set of political principles or moral
principles on the basis of revealed
wisdom that this holy book supports this
and I've I'll notice this people who I
respect enormous Lee Dave whether it's
Dennis Prager or Michael Medved that are
making the argument that you cannot have
a moral Society without a foundation of
religious belief I would ask them these
are two brilliant Jewish thinkers why
don't you believe that Jesus is the Son
of God it's revealed truth the new
testament says that this is gospel they
don't base ically if you're going that
far with religion and you're saying you
need this revealed truth this belief to
organize a society why not the next
level of the revealed truth or whatever
the next level is or something like that
right they will not take it as simply
necessary truth the fact that the New
Testament claims to be the Word of God
why don't they believe that they're
basing their same belief in the Old
Testament on the same claim that the New
Testament makes they just choose to be
agnostic or atheistic about one of those
holy books I could apply the same
challenge to their belief that the Old
Testament is the revealed truth because
it's simply self self validating so I
would look for a different set of
principles that are does not depend on
one's suspension of disbelief and an
acceptance that something is revealed
truth for my moral code so with that
being said does it matter to you if the
end result is the same right so I'm
gonna guess that on most of the
important issues of the day you probably
agree in large part with both Dennis and
Michael Medved
right and most conservative thinkers
that maybe come from a more religious
background so at the end of the day when
it all washes away do
do you think it really matters do you
think that's sort of a long-term problem
I know I guess if we arrived at the same
place I think it's it it's a problem for
that segment of voters or thinkers who
don't find those appeals particularly
interesting but I have to I'll be very
honest Dave part of my resistance to
this is simply I don't find claims of
petitionary prayer and the idea of a
personal loving God consistent with what
I see what I call the daily massacre of
the innocence
to me it's a very hard claim to make
that I should expect God to pay
attention to my well being when he's
willing to allow horrific things to
happen to people far more deserving and
innocent that I am so for me it's partly
just a truth value I cannot stomach what
appears to me to be a patently false
claim about a personal loving God it's
interesting I've mentioned that I've had
John Kasich in here who's the former
governor of Ohio and presidential
candidacy and when I asked him about
faith he said something that I that
sounded sort of almost flippant but I
thought it was really actually pretty
insightful he said you know some people
can do it with God I just can't and I
thought that was actually like you know
for a certain set of people they where
you're able to sort of always sort of
maybe go back to your intellectual side
some people just sort of get tired of
that does that well I and I also think
it's a very I think its genetic I know
that I am not particularly predisposed
towards metaphysical questions because I
don't think they can really be answered
so the idea of what started the universe
we can't really answer that I think that
to say god that's just a placeholder for
ignorance right that doesn't help you
know cause here with Prager regress you
know so where did God come from it just
it's just putting off that moment of
ignorance a little bit further so I
don't find those questions particularly
relevant on the other hand I recognize
that for much of humanity that is
very deep need to ask these basic
questions about origin and an end point
where we all headed what is the meaning
of life to me anybody who claims that
they don't he doesn't find meaning in
life when there is Mozart and Haydn to
invoke a dennis prager favorite or
Beethoven or John Milton or Aeschylus or
Anthony Trollope or just whatever you do
doing trying to do the best you can do I
don't find life meaningless for one
second yeah so does it worry you then
when Republicans or more broadly
conservatives talk about God all the
time or now that we're seeing sort of a
huge fracture and what's happening with
the left they're like completely afraid
to even mention God or anything like
that Bernie I think is basically an
atheist although he won't really say it
because I think there would be political
repercussions but are you like does that
make you sort of feel not totally at
home with the conservatives well you
know I I grew up in a very secular
environment and so it was a novel
discovery to me in the 90s when I was in
a more conservative writing circle and I
grew up as a default liberal I hadn't
been exposed to religion I mean it is an
amazing thing I had been educated on the
coasts and I didn't realize how
different they were so in one sense I'm
very parochial and I haven't been
exposed to the degree of religious faith
I guess I find it I'm always amazed what
to me seems parochialism when I hear
successfully Christians in a political
environment getting up there and talking
about Jesus as God my view immediately
is well there are Jews around you know
at the ferries and there are Muslims
yeah how can you be so confident that
everybody in this audience is of that
particular faith and I also would notice
simply that religion has been tamed by
the Enlightenment it has now been taught
to mind its manners and sit quietly in
the corner mm-hmm we all you know the
the great kissing wisi between Jews and
Christians that we all now talk about
the judeo-christian environment i herod
heritage and perhaps rightly so that's a
novel thing right it wasn't like that
it was exactly yeah and all these
religious supporters are saying we
cannot live without it
they are conveniently overlooking what
the history of religion has been in our
tradition and still is in many other
places that have not gone through the
Enlightenment the concept of tolerance
is not a religious concept it's an
Enlightenment concept and religion in in
the West has been forced to accept
tolerance which is a very good thing but
that is not an idea that is inherent to
religion right so I don't want to be
Prager or medvetz no don't lawyer at the
moment but I think what they would say
is that it was the it was all the
religious stuff that organized society
that allowed us to get to the
Enlightenment so that the Enlightenment
could then you know unfurl all these
good ideas well I don't think I don't
think Christianity or judeo-christianity
has any necessary monopoly on moral
virtues I think there's a certain core
sense of I don't know any culture that
says murder is okay but every culture
starts to assert distinctions what they
don't last that long right yeah it's fun
for a moment you know you get to give it
to your your most aggressive tendencies
right where do you think Trump falls out
on this because I don't think anyone
really thinks he's a religious person or
perhaps even a believer in any real
sense of it yet Christians or
evangelicals especially really seem to
like the job that he's doing well I
don't think he has particular principles
or deep thoughts about much of anything
I think he will he's a chameleon he
takes on the coloring of what is
convenient at the time so whether he
believes or not I I don't know he I
don't think he's thought much deeply
about it either
and it doesn't really matter but
certainly he's willing to speak that
read or
in order to get get that vote and it is
it's an interesting question I mean can
we're more ready to have a gay
politician probably than somebody who is
an avowed non-believer which isn't
interesting so taking the other side of
this as we watch sort of this internal
civil war of the Democratic Party
between the Socialists and I would you
know the last few remaining and decent
liberals or whatever you want to call
them I I do see a connection between not
necessarily belief but they no longer
have any sort of guiding principle that
they believe in other than the state do
you see something like that like they've
not that you need God or you're gonna
have the state but because they have
something they have almost nothing it's
starting from nothing other than the
state they just want that state to grow
and grow and grow well you're sort of
making an argument that I hear a lot
which is that the left progressives
liberals are relativist their moral
relativists I don't that's not what I
see I see an absolute dogmatism they
just have a different set of values or
virtues of in which they are absolutely
convinced I mean they think that they
know the truth of American that truth is
one of endemic enduring white supremacy
and that everybody unless he has been
proven otherwise is filled with bigotry
and hatred so I see them as as
judgmental as the worst caricature of of
Puritans so I wouldn't say it's a an
amoral view and it's not one that is
particularly individualistic it's it's
group based mm-hmm
and identity based yeah does it seem to
you that the remaining piece of whatever
the Democratic Party is that it is just
can't hold I mean aoc who I think is
pretty much wrong about everything she
did say something a couple weeks ago
that I thought was relatively insightful
which is that she basically as a
socialist well you know they still call
themselves democratic socialists but
first part soon enough but that she
shouldn't be in the same party as Joe
Biden and that strikes me is actually
true what are these people doing in the
same party Bernie Sanders and
Larry Clinton should not be in the same
party that this thing just can't hold
much longer well I don't know I think
that that's the gravity is is with the a
OCS and I would love to see a very
strong defense of the free-market system
of individual entrepreneurship of the of
the nobility and bravery and courage but
is there is there at I mean is there an
even Biden like he's the last vestige of
I know they won't they won't they won't
so what do you think that is that would
lead someone like Biden that you know
that he's not one of these people like
what do you think that is that weakness
point I think that the idea that there
is a Western culture has been so
devalued there's a constellation of
complaints of accusations that are
deeply intertwined and it is involved
with identity positive I think I think
that the identity politics is what's
going to take this culture down but I
think to support capitalism you are
leaving yourself open to supporting
white male capitalism and white male
entrepreneurship and so I think what
Biden fears would be less being accused
of being a hard-hearted vulture on the
body politic as being somehow involved
in a long tradition that led to
colonialism that led to imperialism and
that leads to oppression by white males
of everybody else so that's what I think
is going to prevent him from giving a
strong throated and full full
enthusiastic defense of the values of of
capitalism and for me the question is
again as we mentioned before the the the
Marc Benioff Salesforce you know the the
Jeff Bezos is of the world when are they
going to demand a candidate that will
defend their right to become
billionaires legitimately because they
created products that the world over is
high
during four isn't it pathetic then we
see Tom Styer up there and he's like
Peggy he's like a little puppy dog
around Bernie just like me like well
it's cuz he doesn't want to get sent to
the gulag what's Bernie's in power
politicians I mean they still have this
incredible power you know and he's not
about to say he occasionally invokes
that I did create something and of
course yes to have is his humble roots
right but he's not about to say I did
something that you guys would have a
clue to do which is mastering the supply
chain right do you think it's funny that
the the billionaires that are thought of
as the good guy billionaires so you know
Bill Gates is thought of as good let's
say Warren Buffett is thought of as good
you know Koch brothers bad or whoever
the right ones are bad but the ones that
are thought it was good they sort of
think that they can give away enough
money or say enough things that it will
save them but it will never save them
right in the eye ultimately of the base
no matter they could give away
everything they can destroy their
fortunes and empires and it just it will
never end yeah and there's things they
just don't realize that or it's like you
just have to do it no matter what
because you'd want to survive do they
not realize that yeah I don't they don't
really have a choice
but they are playing with fire I mean
they have to realize that the extent
that they continue feeding this and Marc
Benioff is just a great example there is
in in San Francisco promoting this idea
that the San Francisco's not done enough
to help the homeless and you know we
need to save the children and whatnot
through just endless bulking up of the
bureaucracy without dealing with the
profound questions of norms public norms
of behavior you know he probably thinks
he can buy exoneration but it's just
it's not going to happen because again
it's all connected
you know this the same left that is has
been dominating homeless politics in San
Francisco for decades the Coalition on
homelessness they are connected to the
entire woke discourse whether it's
regards to illegal aliens or you know
white supremacy or male toxic mess
it's all it's all part of the same thing
so let's shift actually towards the the
homeless portion of those kids I watched
this morning a talk that you did about
the San Francisco situation which
everyone knows is horrific I've told
this story a million times but when I
was there about a year ago I went out to
dinner with a friend and we were at
Morton's Steakhouse so it's a nice
Street we're on supposedly nice Street
our car got broken into right outside
the restaurant they stole my bag and my
notebook and all this stuff and I took a
picture of the broken glass and I
tweeted it out and I kid you not I got
hundreds if not thousands of responses
basically all saying the same thing Dave
what kind of idiot leaves a bag in a car
in San Francisco because there is such
an epidemic of break-ins that they know
that regular people know not to leave a
bag in a car yeah what is happening up
there
well it's happening across the country
we're in a massive process of de norming
we are unraveling every standard in the
name of racial justice so what happened
in your car that's that's a product of
largely of proposition 47 one of the
ballot initiatives in California that
downgraded a whole bunch of felonies
including felony theft to misdemeanor
status because of the problem of
criminal laws having a disparate impact
on minorities do you think the people
that are pushing these laws that it's
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions always do you think that they
really think they're doing something
good even though all the evidence always
points to the fact that it gets worse
after these policies yeah I don't I
don't I think I've you've said yourself
you're not a big fan of conspiracy
theories I'm not either I really I take
people at their word I think that they
really do believe that the
over-representation of blacks in prison
is due to criminal justice racism and
that we're throwing a whole bunch of of
trivial offenders in prison which is not
the case you have to work very hard to
get yourself a prison sentence most any
big city your triage doubt you you know
if you steal somebody's car a DA is
going to be compiled
lately uninterested in you you have to
steal it at gunpoint with the drivers
still in to get a big-city DA interested
in actually prosecuting your case as
opposed to just giving you probation and
sending you on your way but no I think
that they they really do believe that
the criminal justice system is racist
and that the way to solve that is to is
to not prosecute not put people not and
defang the police and of course the
problem is yes there's a vast
over-representation of blacks in prison
but the thing we should be concerned
about is that blacks are victimized by
crime the most and I go to community
meetings in in inner-city neighborhoods
all the time those good law-abiding
bourgeois residents of high crime
neighborhoods beg for more police
protection those are the voices that
never get heard so when these policies
are put in place or like in New York
City the Blasio is now done this thing
where you're allowed to jump the
turnstile they will not stop you so it's
like you're basically saying to
everybody that pays Yeah right and I
lived in New York City most of my adult
life I never jumped a turnstile you're
basically saying if you pay you're an
idiot
yeah like why should you do it and so
they're actually encouraging more and
more people to not follow the law
I know and aoc has as well I mean this
is really for a politician to defend
turnstile jumping should be that's an
impeachable offense because social norms
are fragile mm-hmm and respect for the
root for the rule of law is the essence
of a civilization we lose that and you
get third world anarchy with everybody
trying to game the system
you know queueing is a thing of beauty
we take it for granted but for people to
be able to quietly wait in line and wait
their place as opposed to trying to you
know get to the top and just muscle
everybody else out break the rules
whatever to get ahead that is a you know
it's been in sort of normal condition
and for respect for the rule of four the
law is incredibly precious and to say it
doesn't matter
and the police should walk on by you are
playing with fire you are on the road to
anarchy do you sense that we're in a
much more precarious place right now
Louise I said that then than we've ever
been or at least more maybe well the
last let's say 50 years something like
that well we have this extraordinary
revolution that nobody foresaw in the
1990s in the eighties the reigning
wisdom and law enforcement itself was
that police could do nothing about crime
that crime was a product of inequality
and injustice and until you solve
poverty and and economic inequalities
all the police could do would respond
after the fact so why even bother so
this is like why New York City and
especially Times Square was a drug den
when I was growing up going into the
city because he's just police were just
walking by the FBI publishes an annual
crime report throughout the 80s they had
a disclaimer saying well of course we
know homicide is a social problem that
the police can't solve so the 90s had
this incredible profound moment where
that whole ideology of passivity before
social Anarchy was turned on its head
and you had mayor Giuliani coming in
Giuliani and his good days I don't know
what's happened to him now it's very
depressing to me but he was the great
one of the greatest mayors if not the
greatest mayor in New York ever had and
his Police Commissioner William Bratton
said no we are actually gonna the police
are gonna lower crime by enforcing the
law and we learned that enforcement
matters you change people's behavior you
deter criminal offending and they
started paying attention to those
low-level crimes in in Times Square the
squalor the the the turnstile jumping
that graffiti the urinating in the
streets and they changed public norms
and and the whole broken windows theory
is correct and even if it doesn't
prevent higher-level crimes it's what
people in high crime neighborhoods beg
for they want public order on the
streets and now that is all being thrown
away and again the reason is disparate
impact so all right so as someone that
deals in fact and that's what your books
that's why my audience digs what you do
do you ever find that sometimes facts
just aren't enough to change the
discourse so it's like alright well then
okay we could probably move on nobody so
how do you how do you deal with that
because I find this to be like the most
sort of strangest place for
conservatives to be right now which is
that most of the facts seem to be on the
conservative side of things at the
moment like it just seems to be reality
right now but I think conservatives have
a really hard time breaking through
either the cultural part I think that's
actually really changing right now
partially because of Trump but sometimes
facts just aren't enough right I mean I
was telling you right when you sat down
might we were talking out the homeless
thing the target that's a half mile from
my house there is a massive homeless
encampment massive I mean it's like a
city there now when I go to target and
it's like well I we could talk about why
some of the reasons that you just laid
out are allowing this to expand but a
lot of people don't want to hear that
well you know this is something that you
have been thinking about for much longer
than I have of how do you change minds
what is the nature of rational discourse
what is its limits and you know we learn
from people like Jonathan hate that in
fact reason often acts as a
after-the-fact justification for
people's instinctive value systems and
ways of looking at the world so well I
would like to claim non ironically that
I have the facts on my side and the fact
I believe that I mean that's what drives
me and it's sort of a hatred of what I
call idiocy I have to acknowledge that
the progressives would say the same
thing they would say my god can't you
see the relevant facts for me one of the
dividing lines between a conservative
and a liberal outlook is that liberals
or progressives will tend to see
structural explanations for inequality
as the most powerful ones and
conservatives are more inclined to see
individual choice personal risk
instability personal behavior as more
significant and leading to ultimate
social outcomes with with economic
disparities and so a a liberal is gonna
say but can't you see the facts of
people growing up in very different
economic circumstances there's not equal
opportunity yet so how can we possibly
demand one single set of behaviors from
people that and they would not view the
facts for me like probably the most
profound fact of our social existence
today is the breakdown of the family and
if this continues going you cannot have
a civilization that way right but but
anything so it's right well that's the
thing if you say that to them iMovie see
this all the time if you say that to
them what do they say race races you're
a racist right so so you're being
extremely kind to them by saying that
they're dealing in their facts but it's
like they're dealing in their facts that
just sort of a different layer that the
real facts are beneath yeah you know I
generally again I'm not gonna say that
all of the hypocrisy or blindness is on
one side and the other I will however
say this I do think that the silencing
tactics of liberals are not symmetrical
I don't think that that conservatives
have that all-purpose silencing tactic
which is to call somebody a racist so in
that respect I do think that there is a
there is more open-mindedness on the
side of of conservatives but again all I
can say you know you've been in these
environments as well you know all the
arguments they have arguments we don't
find them persuasive they don't find our
arguments per se so how you change minds
in the face of that is the big mystery
of our time and you know I know that
again I grew up a liberal default what
changed my mind is starting to do
reporting and go into environments like
I was in the I started doing journalism
in the 90s in this great Renaissance of
New York under mayor Giuliani who was
taking on one sacred cow after another
whether it was the welfare and dust
real complex or the the crime
justifications and I would go to
homeless shelters and I would go to
welfare offices and I would talk to the
clients mm-hmm and I would hear things
that the left would characterize is oh
that's just Ronald Reagan you know his
his disparagement of wealth God's the
welfare clients themselves would say you
know these welfare mothers they're just
having more babies to increase their
welfare check you and I would say the
New York Times goes here how do they not
hear this well they know they don't want
to hear it I don't know it's to counter
to the narrative yes one of the most
interesting examples of what you just
said there David Horowitz once told me
this story this he told me this
privately I'm sure I can say it publicly
he wasn't on the show but he said that
he was in the in New York City in the
early 80s when the AIDS crisis was
booming and this is right when he sort
of made his conversion from a lefty to a
conservative and he said that they all
knew it was coming out of the gay bath
houses you know these people are having
orgies and there's drugs and all this
stuff and they knew it was proliferating
and it was killing people and that
basically the Republicans the
Conservatives said we have to close down
the bathhouses because there's this
massive public health crisis and the
Democrats because the road to hell is
paved with good intentions
said you guys are a bunch of homophobe
yeah you can't tell gay people what to
do so they they were trying to do
something guys we like gay people let
them do whatever they want the
Republicans sort of sound mean we're not
going to let the gays do that and then
what did it do it exacerbated the
situation even more so there's a lot of
that what you just laid out there and I
would also say I mean this is another
classic example of the divide between
liberals and conservatives you you know
the the liberal definition is somehow
this is Ronald Reagan's fault and AIDS
is treated as a airborne disease without
the fat acknowledgment that it is
absolutely behaviorally motive you can
avoid it a hundred percent by not
engaging in certain behaviors by acting
personally responsible you can say the
same thing about campus rape yeah well
not a hundred percent just to be totally
clear you could get a transfusion that's
that's not that's minor part yeah you
know the real transmission was in sin
sexual contact and that's true in Africa
for heterosexual sex as well but again
that reluctance to say there are things
that individuals can do that ironically
I mean it's look at it just notice they
tend to be things that do conform to
traditional behaviors which is sexual
prudence and and modesty and
self-restraint protect you and I again
let me just say the campus rape thing
it's the same thing you could avoid a
hundred percent virtually hundred
percent what is called campus rape by
four on the females part by not getting
drunk and getting in bed with a guy you
barely know because the amount of
stranger rapes going on on college
campuses are minut they barely that's
meaning just a guy that finds a girl
walks into your gets into your breaks
into your room and and you know uses
knife for or force most of the campus
rape is a voluntary sexual encounter
that is a hundred percent avoidable if
you don't want to get involved so you
know that that's gonna be the part that
gets ya so when you I believe women have
power you know what I don't want to I
don't want to give any of the sort of
nauseating strong feminist bromides here
but the fact of the matter is is that
females do have power to determine most
of the outcomes of their lives today
especially today so then the message
though that we hear when we hear about
this campus rape epidemic it really you
know I guess so the way you're framing
it is that it boils down to there it's
almost as if the left that's pushing
this they think women have no capacity
or their own why did fantasizing it's
say now this has been pointed out many
times the rules on campus are a male
who's very drunk
is responsible for his actions and the
actions of the female a female who is
very drunk
has no responsibility for herself and
she certainly doesn't have
responsibility for the for the male now
I would frankly be very happy if we go
through a full-throated revival of
Victorian eath ethics I believe that
chivalry is an important value
and it civilize Ismail's that for males
to regard females as something worthy of
respect and to to rein in their power
and and strength to have a sense of
dignity of females and of themselves
that's a very good thing and I also
believe it's a very good thing for
females to realize that the male libido
is not the same to be honest about the
extraordinary hunger of the male libido
and to exercise their own control over
that but you can't have it both ways you
can't decide that we're gonna celebrate
female promiscuity at the same time that
you're gonna hammer males for taking
advantage of the sexual caravanserais
that we've created right and then you
hear these crazy stories I'm sure you
heard the one a couple of months ago
about the guy and girl that got drunk
and then the next morning they both
accused each other of rape because they
because they basically wanted to beat
the other one to the punch sure the
principles absolutely do the principles
right and so much of this is also just
you know oh she's not my boyfriend right
you know absolutely and then social
media just brings this thing to a whole
other level right because then just
everyone is just add everyone's throats
well we're desperate to find another
example of rape culture it's very hard
to find you know in fact again what
would be rape call it like when they say
we have a rape culture
rape culture really would be certainly
it's not in America I mean they're
Afghanistan it's it's like it's like
being forced to be in a hut and may Paul
in rural Nepal if you're menstruating
you know it's it's a tolerance for group
rape that is finally you know people
women in India are finally trying to
sort of push back against this but in a
lot of Afghan villages it's you know the
problem is now the the female is now
banned from from the village because
there was rape with force but please do
not tell me that that females in in this
country are victimized by rape culture
in fact females from the time that they
are sentient
are the target of non-stop messages of
female empowerment you go girl code
girls who code whatnot
it's insensate incessant it's the males
in our culture today who get no positive
encouragement and they are withdrawing
you know there's the failure of males
you can see it in the social indicators
is huge because it was IED raids always
absolutely they are told that they are
the bearers of toxic masculinity and
this is a very dangerous thing that
we're playing with what tools have you
seen to get men out of it I mean I think
Jordan Peterson was as close to a sort
of mass move to yes young men out of
this thing
right I think we need more voices like
you and and Peterson and if somebody was
a political genius to try and organize
your followers because they're out there
but they need to be more vocal and more
empowered I mean one of the things I
love but again this is this is precluded
by the moment we live in
I think the Boy Scouts was one of the
greatest inventions you know this was an
invention to try and help poor
inner-city kids that were themselves the
subject of breakdown of social mores but
it gives boys a code of virtue and
goodness and honesty and achievement but
unfortunately the gay lobby thought the
Boy Scouts out of existence corporate
money dried up you have never seen such
a thing of beauty as an inner-city Scout
Troop I've been in based church
basements in Bensonhurst Brooklyn to see
these little kids tying knots pledging
allegiance to the flag it breaks my
heart that corporate America has been
bludgeoned into supporting inner-city
scouting because the the employees said
you cannot support a homophobic
institution that is that is terrible it
is tragic all right so let's dive into
that a little bit so so I'm with you
that the gay lobby they attacked and
tried to basically destroy the Boy
Scouts boat you you as a person would
you
I know you don't want to push your
values on the Boy Scouts per se would
you have cared if there had been a gay
Scoutmaster you personally I wouldn't
have cared on a because that's really
what they what it seemed to avoid boil
down to and I love guys I don't know I
you know I would be sympathetic with
parents who were worried about child
abuse on a on a camping trip it's a mine
it's a small risk but it is a risk
nonetheless I'm sorry let's be honest it
is a risk so I would say the good
compromise was keep it you don't have to
be out about it perhaps but I just don't
think I don't think that issue is
relevant for the vast majority of
scouting especially again in the inner
city it's just not relevant for these
kids they don't whether they what their
stance is on homosexuality doesn't
really matter right see well that's the
part that so I it doesn't matter I would
want to know what the numbers bear out I
suppose relative to like a predator
infiltrating and then molesting a kid
obviously you don't want that but yes I
think the way that the lobby comes in
and then just bludgeons them too you got
to do what we want you to do that's sort
of destroying all the goodness there I'm
completely in line with you on that one
yeah I guess I would just say again like
it the kids are more important than
asserting gay I did there's plenty of
other places to have gay pride it
doesn't you don't have to do it in the
Boy Scouts so with that in mind are you
concerned that all of our institutions
are going to succumb to this stuff like
it seems like everything they already
have no no it is not I mean I know you
think that 2020 is going to be the the
year it all crashes apart well I think I
think politics is is self defeating
can't go any further I wish I shared
that so what I yes so I'm basically that
why what I think is gonna really happen
not that it will ever burn out
completely because I think it is so
psychotic and nature and unhinged from
reality but I think this'll
will cause it to have a necessary split
something like that so the split that we
talked about earlier about the AOC and
Biden should not be in the same party I
think enough people are gonna fully
realize that that the social justice
worries will carve out whatever their
thing is and then the other sane people
will have to decide are we still
Democrats or are we going to become
Republicans but yes I don't know will it
crash to the point of that they're gonna
give up well these people show no signs
of ever giving up well again I hate to
sound apocalyptic but again message that
I know that I'm inclined towards that by
definition but it is impossible to
overstate the the power of the assault
on meritocratic standards in our culture
today colorblind gender-blind
meritocratic standards there's not a
single institution that is not on the
defensive if it has any kind of
achievement standard that has any kind
of disparate impact that does not result
in exact proportional representation
whether it's 50/50 males or females or
you know minority based representation
any any standard whether it's in the
STEM fields in science that does not
result in in that Halcyon proportional
representation is now under assault
everybody some Christian private school
right that has withstood some of this
something like that that's the
conservative yes yeah maybe I'm always
cheered on whenever I see a panel that's
coming out of some think-tank and it's
all males I think you know and frankly
let's be honest I mean what I track is
the natural experiments that that is
that they absolutely explode the
feminist explanation because they're so
there are a few institutions out there
without any gatekeepers and so it allows
you to test you know the the explanation
for lack of fifty-fifty male/female is
inevitably sexist discrimination so
let's look at the places with no
gatekeepers a that's Wikipedia mmm-hmm
the editors of Wikipedia there's no
barrier
there's no historical preference oh I
don't know where you're going this place
but it ends up being for women it's
overwhelmingly male why because males on
average and I'm not talking about your
daughter Ben Rubin they're Dave Rubin
listener you know she's gonna be a no
belet's but on average yes males are
more interested in facts and things in
ideas in accuracy in sports trivia and
they're the ones that want to get
involved in that discourse recently we
saw there was the historic matchup of
three greatest jeopardy winners they
were on male if you look at I wrote
about Scrabble championship there's no
barriers to entry for Scrabble like all
of the winners throughout history of a
very short history have all been male so
if we were to take this back to what we
discussed earlier we're then the lefties
would maybe look at a separate SEC set
of facts to explain that they would say
something like well it's because we
teach boys to care more about math yeah
or something like that and we just say
know that there's biology before that
absolutely absolutely the turns out the
most gender equal countries are the ones
that have the biggest disparities in
preference for professions right so this
is the Sweden experiment exactly exactly
and and again this has not been the case
for so long we've had again strong
females together that has been the ethos
of American education now for decades it
is just not possible to say that females
are being discouraged from math it
they're being encouraged at every single
moment that there's any male
mathematicians is a miracle it just
shows how strong that imperative is at
the extreme versions again we all know
the distribution curves males are the
worst math dummies but they also at the
highest end the the most math gifted do
you think that there's just a certain
amount of cognitive dissonance that
comes with us a lot of this like did you
happen to see a couple weeks ago Steven
sent out a tweet that he's against
diversity in arts because of course you
wouldn't want painters and authors and
creative people to have to have some
sort of diversity quota but this guy's a
lefty progressive you know the whole
thing and he's definitely for diversity
quotas and all the other things but not
in arts huh and I think it's partly
because he's an artist yeah so it's like
not in my field because we're creative
and creativity should always rise to the
top but for you people but in essence
what he's saying is well doctors and
pilots see the rest of you you should it
should be based on skin color and
sexuality and Valhalla but not artists
cuz word hilarious well I'll take it I
mean if he's he's actually willing to
defend there too because that is I mean
anybody who subjects himself to the New
York Times arts pages that it's all it
is it's all it is is diversity female
and people of color diversity so his
position it may be a narrow one but I'll
take it
because right because they're the
kernels there at least right so that
it's like maybe something can grow out
of yes but it's also on the other hand I
really relish the fact that Hollywood is
being pressed to sacrifice its best box
office judgement yeah for the gods of
diversity you know and are they where
you know they're absolutely torn which
do they do do they choose to have female
remakes you know that may not be the box
of cells or may not be as good in order
to placate the you know the Oscar
bean-counting and the Golden Globe
bean-counting or do they just say to
hell with it we're just gonna tough it
out I don't know I don't know yeah but
it's really great yeah what are the
interesting times limits I sense you're
pretty enthused about sort of the way
the world is it like everybody sort of
seems everyone feels like it's crazy
it's never been worse we hate each other
more than ever poor I mean I think all
of that is nonsense anyway and social
media makes us all feel a little crazier
yeah but you seem to even though this is
serious stuff I mean you're talking
about institutions all being infected as
you're talking to me yeah but it's a
pleasure to be have a fellow skeptic
here and and I would say to get back to
an earlier question of yours you know
are we heading towards a point of no
return and how to
get back from this this is the most
difficult thing the way we actually
demolish identity politics and again the
the founding engine of this is disparate
impact we have to counteract the myth of
bias that as long as the only allowable
explanation for socio-economic
disparities is the tana he see Coates
view of the world the Michelle Alexander
view of the world that everything is
driven by bias the aoc world they win
but if we've lost the schools already
which I suspect do you think we have
certainly certainly at the college level
but even if we've lost each other yeah
he's lost all of that then suddenly this
rosy picture gets a lot more murky right
yes I am NOT I'm not a rosy person all I
know is the way we get it back is to
start giving alternative explanations
and then if people are terrified to talk
about no excuse me there are behaviors
the education gap I mean what we see now
it's tragic
your average black 12th grader reads the
level of your average white 8th grader
that is HUGE forty percent of black 8th
graders on the National Assessment of
Educational Progress this is one of
these national standardized tests forty
percent of black 8th graders do not even
have basic math skills basic is the most
it's you know simple arithmetic those
types of statistics make this
expectation of proportional
representation ludicrous we're yet the
cowardice on the part of our mainstream
institutions cannot be overstated within
the last couple of weeks the American
physics Association the premier
professional organization for physicists
came out with the complete
predictable chest-beating Mia culpa
saying if we do not have proportional
black physicists it's because we are
biased
there must be bias in our credential
izing in our physics education these are
people who were supposed to believe
you're smart if they can't look at the
data human actually in many ways it's
anti human it's saying you have no
control you know but what has to happen
is there has to be a major change in
inner-city black culture to get rid of
the anti acting white stigma there has
to be behavioral change a different
attitude towards academic accomplishment
but as long as the myth of bias as long
as bias is the only explanation that as
long as the American physics society
Association is not feel itself able to
say there needs to be more studying
students have to take their textbooks
home in K through 8 less truancy nothing
is going to change do you think in a
weird way that Asians might be the key
to this whole thing that basically
Asians will get fed up being quoted
against not getting into Harvard even
though no one gave Asian people anything
just like no one gave my ancestors
anything or anything but Asians may just
be like you know what Harvard is
actually everyone talks about systemic
racism Harvard is actually put it in the
system it's harder to get in if you're
Asian right right and now the courts
have said that's actually okay right
which is bananas but that basically
Asian people will get so fed up even
though they're not a very vocal minority
they'll get so fed up about being
genuinely discriminated against but
perhaps that fixes the problem I mean
it's almost a very backwards way of
looking at this thing but no it's a
great idea and and indeed the Chinese in
New York now there's also a big Chinese
parent movement because bill de blasio
and his utterly terrifying Carranza yeah
are trying to destroy again every
meritocratic standard get rid of it it's
all going to be based on quotas so the
Chinese parents there are protesting the
destruction of Stuyvesant High School
assets
but on the other hand it's really a race
against time because Harvard in its
recent lawsuit defending itself against
Edie Blum and the and the challenge to
its its discrimination against Asians
they assembled a big crew of Asian
Harvard students who were defending
preferences and so can you play with
their rationale was I heard I heard a
couple versions of this just diversity
and you know we got in so like it didn't
hurt us but but they I think the
rationale is is that the lore of
identity politics and being anti white
is the key to the elite the elite
identity in this country now is is
against establishment values and it's
against meritocracy and it's a it's a
commitment to the idea of white
supremacy so to the extent that colleges
can end up cloning Asian students in
their own image of identity politics and
it is happening I mean you can go to UC
Berkeley you know the the degree of
specialization of the different ethnic
groups there you know so you have the
Filipino Club in the and the you know
Samoan Club where everybody there's
power and victimhood and you know the
the sort of laughable irony is that so a
lot of these left-wing Asian students
want to be viewed as a students of color
you know please PLEASE were students of
color as well the irony is is that the
administration said no you're not
students going you don't count if you're
minority thing doesn't count you're
white for the sake of our quotas your
guys are white so the poor students and
wait a minute wait for now there's
there's super white they're not just
white right like they're Android they
Trump whites that's right
whites are actually you know get
preferences over Asians so I don't know
that's it's a really good question about
self-interest versus ideology and again
the lore of ideology and we see this and
also with Indians Indian Americans in
this culture there
that'll be the next one they are very
left-wing mm-hmm but do you think that
that they'll sort of suffer the fate of
Chinese Americans or something like that
and that eventually it'll turn on them
too and yeah they're discriminated
against I mean the head of Google the
guy who fired James d'amour for writing
you've talked about this you know a
perfectly fact-based memo about
psychological truths things that the
psychology profession is known for years
about the big five personality traits
one of which unfortunately it's called
neuroticism poor poor mr. innocent
d'amour yeah use the word neuroticism
and everybody freaked out but that's
sorry that's the psychology terms James
Moore who by the way had gotten a
promotion for his job just two months
before the memo he's a perfect he's a
fantastic he's a fantastic engineering
would have held Google but God forbid he
put females at risk for saying that the
reason there's not more females here is
because average distribution of
personality you know preferences anyway
but sundar Pichai he's Indian American
you know so and a lot of the schools
Chancellor's in the University of
California that are doing all of the
multiculturalism bs there are Indian
engineers so it's very curious the trans
thing a lot of the parents are Indian so
again it shows the gravitational force a
victim identity that that is how you
credential eyes yourself to enter the
American elite is to buy into this idea
that this is a racist and sexist society
so you just briefly mention the trans
thing there have you read Douglas
Murray's madness of crowds by any chance
so you know one of the things that I
think he brilliantly does is he
separates the tea from LGB he says these
things have nothing to do with each
other
do you basically take that position and
sort of see why the trans movement has
sort of spun off into something that's
completely not about equality now yeah
it's clearly a power play why anybody
takes these 14 16 year-olds seriously at
face value the the desire of every
adolescent is power it is to be able to
bend adults and the world to your will
and this is the most brilliant Greta
Sundberg
exactly drew but to be trans has even
more power because you can trip people
up in an ever more arcane linguistic
thicket and if they make the most
innocuous linguistic error they are
guilty and so you are it is a way of
asserting power over the world and and
it's endlessly fertile and fecund it
generates more and more categories and
it is something amazingly I mean nobody
thought about this five years ago and
now we're all supposed to believe that
this represents some essential truth
about human nature where again it is
just a way of clawing to the top of the
viciously competitive totem pole of
victimhood and being top dog for as long
as it lasts you know and who knows you
know big big sweepstake award whoever
can come up with the next victim that
will dethrone the trans identity but it
will come right that and that's gonna be
a big one yeah what that wait you know
to look forward to right so I take it
when biden said that when you're going
to jail you should be able to pick which
prison and go to decide dependent on
your decision about your own gender
you're not a big fan of that nobody can
look at it to the power there you are a
prisoner and you get to flip the tables
and say now you state prison authority
or federal prison authority you have to
bend to my will
it's just incredible I remember the time
it was maybe the summer of 2014 the
Times ran a front full-page editorial
announcing the dawn of the transi era
that this was the new civil rights
campaign and it's just not true again
there is a very minut number of people
for whom this is authentically a
psychological disorder but I think for
most of it I've talked to college
campuses and I don't really address the
transfer dominant but in one talk at st.
Olaf I just gave I read a section a
piece
prose that was written by some trans guy
who was all his head was all like tied
in knots because he was trying to figure
out when his gay friends called each
other she and her in a gay rhetoric and
then they referred to this trans person
Alex as she and her whether they were
respecting his identity disrespecting
her I thought and my point was this is
so trivial yeah this is so trivial you
guys should be thinking about things
outside of yourself how about you lose
yourself in the past
that's difference so I but that was my
only reference to this and this girl
came up to me afterwards and said you're
not expecting my identity this was just
again another pitch for power mm-hmm and
you know where it goes but it's it's
ridiculous it is not something that is
the a civilizational truism you know
that this is something we should all
take that seriously yeah
this seems to be the one I think that is
actually helping let's say our side the
most because it is so patently absurd if
you just can't say that there are
biological differences between men and
women that doesn't make you a bigot it
doesn't make you a transfer but doesn't
mean you hate women yeah but it's
something that we all just like we just
know right my four-year-old niece knows
there's a difference between boys and
girls not a rocket scientist
so something it's almost like this one
they overshot to the point that it might
cause a little bit of a bounce-back
which goes to again my prediction of the
implosion of this thing but look at
North Carolina I I don't know I mean
there you had this conservative state
that buckled under corporate pressure
again corporations everybody thinks
there's a OC thing Oh big business evil
white supremacy no or you get them to do
almost anything corporations they've all
got the CEOs have wives and wives are
disaster you know they've pushed their
they push husbands to the left and they
have human resources departments as as
the Google employees said in one of the
chat rooms after d'amore was fired we
have to kick this thing back because our
HR department known in googling
languages people analytic
because you can't just call it human
human resource he said it's just an
outpost of women's studies and black
studies now so these corporations are
promoting the trans thing and far too
many parents are I mean I I did think
that when the dictate started coming
down that parents have to let their girl
their daughters have biological males in
their locker rooms and bathrooms that
there would be just pitchfork battles
and it didn't happen I keep waiting for
the massive rejection of this it's not
happening school after school district
is enacting trans policy so you show me
where besides that navitor OVA and and
and Rowling's yeah that this is actually
put any kind of dent in this crusade
well I think I think Ricky Gervais is
speech at the Golden Globes where he
just torched identity politics and
torched this very town that we're in
right now I think JK rowling thing I
think Martina speaking up and then hurt
them attacking her about yeah athletes I
think that I think it's just starting to
bubble up okay which way that goes we
don't know but I think there I think
it's people are getting a little bit
braver I hope so don't burn this book
comes out on April 28th it's about
giving people I'm sure
the keys to the bravery thing believe me
when everybody's got it in their
calendar marks yeah all right we all
have a couple minutes left you you you
plow through so much information at once
and I feel like we've been talking for
10 minutes but it's been about an hour
already over time so what what else has
sort of been on your mind lately like
what what is something that maybe I'm
not tracking or that you think regular
folks aren't tracking that you sort of
see is another frontier we're gonna have
to be fighting on
oh man that that's a bad question
without an answer well you you said
what's going to be the spectacular one
that knocks trans off this but is there
something else that you're sort of
seeing new data on or justthat speaking
your interest lately mmm no I'm just
paying a lot of it I still for me my
heart lies in universities I you know
for me there's no greater good than the
privilege of being able to study the
great war
and so I keep hoping that there will be
pushback there
I guess I've seen there are some signs
of hope in a movement to start classical
academies at the K through 12 level that
are explicitly dedicated to teaching the
great books without identity politics I
think that movement has to be supported
I wish philanthropists would do more to
to put their money behind beauty and wit
and irony and greatness and sublimity I
think that nobody's cracked the problem
of the college credential izing and the
the fierce hunger of these allegedly
left-wing parents - you know credential
eyes their child with the most status
producing diplomas possible I would love
to see a movement to have a revival of
tutors which used to be the way that
people got educated so homeschooling for
college kids because we've got to shut
these institutions down so that you
could other way I think that's happening
right now because of YouTube I think the
amount of stuff that people are learning
from pretty brilliant people many of
whom have sat in that chair and plenty
of other shows I think that's happening
already I think people are being deep
well the New York Times did you see the
New York Times piece a couple weeks ago
about Prager you terrified circumventing
parents and professors to teach people
right-wing views and it's like they try
to make that sound scary but oh right
it's like thank God right I mean I adore
Prager you I adore Dennis Prager I would
say those he's doing basically political
topics which is absolutely necessary he
is taking on the lies that are so
distorting our world that he's not
taking people through books 1 through 12
of Paradise Lost
mm-hmm one needs time one needs depth
one needs focus and so I would love to
see basically there's a lot of graduate
schools in this department now that are
not in this country that are not
accepting white males because they know
they are not going to get a job I mean
it white males boys are doomed
at this point unless we turn this around
you know I can't remember if I told you
this last time you were here but the guy
who did the lighting in my studio is a
you know we're in LA here so you get
great people to do things he's an Emmy
award-winning lighting guy he's in his
mid-60s been in the business for 40
some-odd years huge lefty lefty lefty
lefty progressive the whole thing we get
into all sorts of political debates and
then we kind of put it aside it's okay
cuz he's cuz he's a he's a progressive
of a certain age so he doesn't have to
want to kill you talk he can do it no
I'll kill you then anyway he did our
lighting he did a spectacular job I
spoke to him a few months ago and he
told me that he was told by an HR person
at a major studio here in LA I won't say
which studio that as a white guy and 60s
he should probably think about retiring
yep absolutely and then suddenly when he
called and said Dave you haven't been as
crazy as well a lot of people process
that yeah the lease Siegel this writer
had an op-ed in the New York Times
recently about his depression and the
America you know we've got this crisis
of mental health with I'm a little
skeptical about but anyway he said well
as a white is a 62 year old white male
you know I of course I I really support
the movements that it basically made me
completely superannuated you know so he
sees it too yeah it's just remarkable
yeah but but anyway I would say if
there's any white males who are still
doing traditional studies in graduate
school and are not getting a job
anywhere they should be tutors you know
have they should say I'll take you on
the Grand Tour we'll go to Rome we'll go
to Florence we'll go to Vienna and we
will read the great books to keep these
books alive because if we don't read
them they die the burden is on us
education is about passing on an
inheritance and we should be down on our
knees in gratitude before works of such
exquisite language and insight into the
human condition instead of this
preposterous conceit of cultural
appropriation I mean some of the most
profound insights into female sexual
psychology and and and
and competition that I but have been
written by males you know should I care
that it's a meal no I don't I just want
beauty and insight so that that's what I
would hope is our next phase to get out
of this man Heather all I have to do is
just live them up for you and you knock
them out of the park it was a pleasure
as always thank you do this again soon
enough and you're not big on Twitter
though you're not you don't fight with
everybody on Twitter a year you're on
the Twitter twitter is just to send out
my recent writings and and appearances a
good enough reason to follow her it's @h
MD at Mi if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell